chaque jour la camionnette de la Poste
marque un arrêt d'une heure dans le
centre de vie socopia
ma mère m'a envoyé ce repas fait maison
[Musique]
c'est la première fois en 8 mois que je
mange la cuisine de ma mère
il y a beaucoup de colis pour les
soldats des cadeaux ou des produits
achetés par correspondance
là j'ai commandé des équipements
supplémentaires je viens de recevoir
ces hommes aimeraient bien une nouvelle
voiture
[Musique]
avisokopiliale les soldats se reposent
quand ils le peuvent
c'est unité a pris ses quartiers dans
cette maison
il y a le Wi-Fi mais ces hommes se
plaignent d'être sous-équipés
plus de 9 fois plus pour l'équipement
non létal de ces troupes que l'année
précédente toujours pas suffisant pour
couvrir tous les besoins
la veste c'est un don les bottes un
autre don ça vient des gens pour
lesquels l'Ukraine compte il nous
fournissent nos uniformes
le ministère de la Défense l'affirme les
uniformes divers sont prêts et
disponibles ces hommes les attendent
avec impatience
on va les repousser encore plus loin
comme ça ils ne pourront pas revenir et
les civils qui vivent ici n'auront pas à
avoir peur que des étrangers arrivent et
les déloges de chez eux
nos courageux petit soldats la
propriétaire de cette maison héberge
volontiers les soldes Ukrainiens pendant
des mois les Russes ont occupé les lieux
regardez ce que le monde russe nous a
apporté ils ont laissé des graffitis sur
les murs des dessins des poèmes
guerriers
toute l'Europe se souvient de nos cris
formidables et face à l'armée russe il
n'est point d'obstacles
comment ça pas d'obstacle mais si un
obstacle un accro un contre-temps il y
aura et ses hommes sont tout ça à la
fois mais ils veulent plus ils veulent
la victoire